argentina es ese país famoso por tener
ese acento que crees que puedes imitar
pero que en realidad no puedes el año
pasado los argentinos cambiaron de
presidente tras 12 años de dominio del
matrimonio kirchner mauricio macri es el
nuevo hombre llamado a dar un giro de
180 grados a este país solo lleva nueve
meses en el poder y en este tiempo los
argentinos ya han sufrido su primer
apagón eléctrico el primero en décadas
ha subido la luz ha subido el desempleo
la inflación está en un 40% y la
popularidad del macri está cayendo en
picado mientras buenos aires- se llena
de protestas pero esperad un momento de
verdad un hombre que no lleva ni un año
en el poder es capaz de destruir el país
tan rápidamente para entender lo que
está ocurriendo en argentina necesitamos
un poquito de contexto histórico de
entrada tenemos que saber que argentina
es el décimo país en recursos naturales
del mundo tienen petróleo gas minerales
y agricultura como para poder alimentar
al 60 por ciento de la humanidad
a principios del siglo 20 argentina era
el quinto país más rico del mundo muy
por encima de austria y muy cerquita de
eeuu de hecho cuando los almacenes
harrods quisieron abrir su primera
tienda fuera del reino unido- no
eligieron nueva york sino buenos aires-
sin embargo en 1930 el ejército da el
primer golpe de estado en argentina
durante estos tiempos la economía
mundial no estaba en su mejor momento
era la época del crack del 29
y eso juntado con la represión de la
dictadura hizo que argentina sufriera
más que ningún otro país
años después se restaura la democracia y
llega al poder un señor que se llama
juan domingo perón
y lo cierto es que pero tampoco fue
capaz de restaurar la economía argentina
sin embargo su carisma y su influencia
llega hasta nuestros días es más podemos
hablar de toda una ideología llamada
peronismo que es una mezcla entre
nacionalismo extremo mercados cerrados
economía muy intervenida y todo
aderezado con la salsa picante del
populismo a partir de aquí la historia
de argentina se puede resumir en un tira
y afloja entre golpes de estado
militares y políticos peronistas que les
suceden en los años 50 el ejército
vuelve a dar otro golpe de estado pero
pero no logra mantenerse en el poder
después otro golpe de estado luego pero
no otra vez años más tarde otro golpe de
estado después gobierno peronista luego
golpe de estado y peronistas golpe de
estado y peronistas así podemos contar
hasta seis golpes de estado con
gobiernos peronistas entre medias el
resultado que a principios del siglo 21
el que fuera el quinto país más rico del
planeta tenía ahora mismo la economía
por los suelos
y estamos ya en el año 2003 y es en ese
momento cuando entra en la casa rosada
el matrimonio más glamuroso de toda la
política internacional los kirchner que
por supuesto son de ideología peronista
y si digo matrimonio porque primero
estuvo el marido néstor y después en
2007 le sucedió a su mujer christine a
las mismas ideas la misma familia vamos
que todo quedó en casa
qué hizo cristina fernández de kirchner
vamos a centrarnos en la época de
christina porque fue la última
presidenta antes de macri y porque
estuvo mucho más tiempo que su marido
una de sus medidas clave fue el impago
de la deuda que tenía argentina con los
inversores internacionales amenazan y
hostigan con acciones sobre la economía
de nuestro país así es como se desató
una guerra entre el gobierno de kirchner
y los inversores principalmente este que
vemos aquí que se llama paul singer y
que luchó hasta el final para que le
devolvieran lo que le debían en ausencia
de un acuerdo con los acreedores gente a
la que se le debe mucho dinero el acceso
a los capitales internacionales está
truncado están pagando muchos más
intereses extra es literalmente miles de
millones de dólares al año
andrew el tema de la deuda externa de
los países es muy complejo y nos va a
dar para otro vídeo pero lo cierto es
que con batallas o sin batallas si tú no
les pagas lo que le debes a los
acreedores es muy difícil que encuentres
nuevas personas dispuestas a prestarse
dinero y esto es lo que le pasó a
argentina
de repente cristina se encontró con que
no podía buscar financiación
mercados internacionales sin embargo su
programa político se basaba precisamente
en aumentar el gasto público desocupados
no registrados registrados con ingresos
altos con ingresos bajos todos están
subsidiados en transporte en luz en gas
en agua y en combustible entonces de
dónde puedes sacar dinero para poder
financiar todos estos subsidios pues
subiendo los impuestos al sector
económico más potente del país que en
este caso era el del cultivo de soja así
que en 2008 cristina puso un tributo de
35 por ciento a la exportación de soja
esto generó muchísimas protestas y hasta
una huelga en el sector que se prolongó
por seis días
en otras palabras kirchner estaba
ahogando su principal sector económico
por eso en poco tiempo cristina se dio
cuenta de que no recaudaba lo suficiente
como para financiar su gasto público y
cuál es la tentación de todos los
políticos cuando no tienen dinero los
que estáis suscritos a visual político
lo sabéis muy bien imprimir billetes sin
embargo cristina no quería subir la
inflación así que junto a esta expansión
monetaria sacó una medida a la que llamó
el cepo cambiario
que el cambio de peso argentino a dólar
americano estaría fijado por ley y os
preguntaréis qué pasa cuando un político
fija un tipo de cambio concreto en lugar
de utilizar el que fija el mercado pues
que aunque el gobierno te diga que un
dólar vale 8 pesos argentinos lo cierto
es que nadie te los va a vender a ese
precio y así es como surgieron dos tipos
de cambios paralelos que los que veis de
este vídeo desde argentina seguramente
ya conoceréis por un lado estaba el
dólar oficial y por el otro el llamado
dólar blue que era el fijado a precio de
mercado de repente las calles de buenos
aires se llenaron de unos señores a los
que llamaban arbolitos que se dedicaban
a venderte dólar blue por supuesto de
forma ilegal usted lo que se lo que se
llama normalmente un arbolito de oro
chino pero si se le llama un arbolito y
entonces quien era capaz de vender
dólares al tipo de cambio oficial pues
solamente una institución que era el
banco central de argentina casi todos
los bancos centrales tienen una reserva
de divisas extranjeras así que en este
caso se dedicaban a vender los dólares
que ya tenían guardados
en estos tres años se perdieron 20.000
252 millones de dólares de las reservas
del banco central el dólar oficial saltó
de 426 pesos a 850 y el blue
protagonista de estos tres años saltó de
4 con 49 a 15 pesos y por eso la
inflación oficial en argentina no era
tan alta pero lógicamente estas
encuestas no reflejaban la vida real de
los ciudadanos y por supuesto no se
tenían en cuenta en el extranjero medios
como the economist rechazaron utilizar
estas estadísticas que proporcionaba el
gobierno argentino por este empeño de
kirchner en ocultar el mercado paralelo
he pasado con mauricio macri lo primero
que hace macri al día siguiente de
llegar a la casa rosada es quitar el
cepo cambiario ese mismo día el cambio
oficial del dólar se multiplica por dos
por supuesto para los que estaban
utilizando el dólar blue no supuso
ninguna diferencia pero para los que sí
que eran capaces de comprar dólares al
tipo oficial tuvo unos efectos
catastróficos en general todos aquellos
negocios que tenían acceso al banco
central de argentina se vieron afectados
y por eso no es que este año haya
crecido la inflación en argentina es que
había estado siempre ahí solo que
camuflados
lo mismo ocurrió con la energía como
hemos visto antes el gobierno de
kirchner subvencionaba la electricidad
que a los argentinos les costaba más o
menos lo mismo que tomarse un café para
pagar estos subsidios argentina llegó a
utilizar más del 16 por ciento del
presupuesto público para que os hagáis
una idea el pago de las pensiones en un
estado normal no llega al 40 por ciento
del presupuesto y en este caso solamente
estamos hablando del 16 para una
subvención muy concreta lógicamente
cuando macri quita el subsidio se
producen protestas en la calle y hasta
un apagón eléctrica
todo esto explica la caída de macri en
los índices de popularidad que ha pasado
en menos de nueve meses de un 66% a un
44% sin embargo los partidarios de macri
aseguran que este 2016 tan horrible es
el precio a pagar para evitar que
argentina se convierta en la nueva
venezuela
y la pregunta es deberíamos culpar a
macri de lo que está pasando oa la
herencia que le han dejado a los
kirchner dicho de otra forma veremos
como caen la inflación y argentina se
empieza a recuperar el año que viene
vosotros qué pensáis me podéis dejar
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
si os interesa este tema y queréis
seguirlo desde cerca suscribiros al
canal para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones como siempre si
queréis profundizar más encontrareis
varios links en la descripción si os ha
gustado este vídeo
dadle a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta pronto